so that question on on your point that
question that the journalists put to um
to boris johnson when he was in poland i
say journalists
it was somebody purporting to be a
journalist who stood well let's let's
let's let's get into this yeah should i
put it up
so i have this here from the week yeah
take a look at this story
ukrainian journalist confronts boris
johnson nato is afraid of world war
three but it has already started this
was a a ukrainian journalist
daria kelinic who had fled ukraine and
was calling on the uk to enforce a
no-fly zone
as soon as you announce a no-fly zone
you're declaring war yeah you are
literally declaring why why there
because you should have done a plane
figure
russian jets
but it's a declaration of war because
you are saying to the other country we
are going to figurative declaration we
got to get away from misusing the word
literal well only congress can declare
war literally no no no no that's that's
legally you're talking about legal yeah
i'm talking about liberal liberal i'm
talking about a literal declaration of
war not a legal one unless you don't
enforce the no-fly zone if you're
enforcing a no-fly zone you have to
shoot russian russian jets down in
ukrainian airspace the minute you do
that it's an act of war well that it's
an act of war but to put it this way it
would be like me saying
sheamus
if you take one step you know in that
direction i'm going to you know we'll
hit you or push you or something i have
declared my intent to attack them that's
that's that's that's not legal yeah and
you right declaration of war is a
specific thing no no no put yourself in
a situation in the united states in the
united states there's certain statute
statutes about declaration of war
completely irrelevant to the actual to
actual war you come people come out here
and they talk about war crimes and all
of this stuff and i'm like these are
like rules put in place by european
councils and conventions to be like dare
i say we shouldn't use this kind of
weapon okay that would be a crime you
talk about real war declaring war is me
saying i am going to shoot you if you do
this no that we did that in vietnam it
wasn't war though it wasn't an official
war it was just the military there yeah
well there was conflict in combat but it
wasn't technically i'm going to say it
one more time because i don't want to
get into static you guys look it up i'm
not lying about it no i i hear what
you're saying about the legal defense
you don't
an american legal understand i'm not i'm
talking about
literal reality
that if you are a country of any type
with regardless of your laws and you say
i intend to shoot you out of the sky you
have declared war against i think war is
a specific term that's that's used in
times of like
specific types of conflict like combat
destruction and conflict doesn't have to
be a war but can you see what he's
saying that if if you shot russian jets
down for example and then russia shot
your your jets down in response and then
you started nuking each other even if
congress didn't declare war you're in i
was going to swear
yeah you're a war on earth you're in war
right if you're doing well even if
congress soldiers would call it that and
they'd say that's his point
the u.s has nothing to do with this stop
thinking about the us
if the if the uk says to russia we
intend to shoot you out of the sky they
have declared war against them i don't
know about any legal parliamentary
statutes about other countries it's
irrelevant
if i am if if my neighbor
is next to me and i tell him if you put
a drone in the sky you know i'll uh
throw a water balloon at it i have
declared my intent to take action
against him should he do something i
don't like now that's what the
i'm going to say journalists advisedly
this lady uh daria kulinik that you've
referenced up there
she called on boris johnson when he was
in poland the uk prime minister to
declare a no-fly zone over ukraine which
would mean we would declare to russia
we're going to shoot you down if you fly
over ukraine right which is an act of
war now it turns out that this person
who called themselves a journalist who
stood up in this press conference
is actually a member of the world
economic forum this is their profile on
the wef website
um if you look up their name and wef you
can see it on your screen there there
they are and actually the bio does not
state journalists
it doesn't state journalists it states
daria is co-founder and executive
director of the anti-corruption action
center a powerful national organization
that has shaped ukraine's
anti-corruption legislation and efforts
by the way anti-corruption became an
agenda because of course the
biden-affiliated biden-aligned uh
america-friendly regime there was
accused of corruption so they set up an
anti-corruption unit to investigate
themselves this was it now this person's
called themselves a journalist and stood
up
calling for boris johnson to enforce a
no-fly zone uh over
uh over ukraine to declare war
declaration of war it's very interesting
to me that they are a member of the uh
world economic forum
yeah i i i have strong opinions on
ukraine and what joe biden did and uh
and hunter
and hunter um and it's all part of the
it's all one big happy family tree son
as they all uh collude to engage in a
tree zone but uh uh
charity call yeah world economic forum
has plainly uh stated that they want
they don't think uh nationalist
governments are capable of governing the
world in its current form but we need
some sort of hybrid corporate governance
with and i think that they're trying to
get countries to blow themselves up so
that they can show that oh yeah you do
need our help to come in and save the
day build back better yeah you got to
destroy before you can build back that's
the point so who is what's a great reset
you have to destroy everything first you
have to reset it and then build back
better so i wonder why certain voices in
the media and you see them openly
encouraging war with russia
and i wonder what what do you want to
build back from the ashes of this war
once you've had your way and that's why
it becomes so important to make sure
they don't get their way there's a great
meme are you familiar with the political
compass no
so uh the political compass is you've
got the authoritarian on top the
libertarian at the bottom oh yeah
you have the authoritarian right you
know fascists traditionalists
uh the meme shows
it's the wojack meme you know it's a bit
paintbrush kind of guy with the squiggly
face and like the evil eyes and each
quadrant is looking towards the center
the f the far left libertarian the
libertarian the far-left authoritarian
and far-right authoritarian are all
looking down at the story of world war
three saying i can't wait for the world
to collapse so i can rebuild this world
in my image yeah
they all believe it and and look
there's a problem here which is that
some way or the other whether it's by
enforcing a no-fly zone in um in ukraine
or it's by directly arming and funding
nazis i worry about the stability of
europe so i'm going to pull something up
for you um i wonder if lydia you can you
can look this up
let me what's that so there's a new york
times article
let me just find the headline for you so
you can search for it give me a second
and what while i'm looking for it what
what it's basically uh
what it's talking about is that because
of this as of battalion that has now
been raised in ukraine
um already we know that internationally
so i've done a lot of work in counter
radicalization and counter extremism
um before being a broadcaster i founded
an organization called quilliam which
was a counter extremism right
organization seeking to help understand
during the global war and terror how to
navigate our way through that from a
muslim background especially because of
course
muslims were central to that debate so
i come at this from that
from that angle when when i look at
radicalization understanding how
radicalization can work
so if you've got a if you've got an arm
nazi battalion that gains victory in
ukraine what that does to radicalization
is incredibly dangerous and there's a
new york times article uh that actually
uh addresses the fact that people now
neo-nazis have been traveling from
around the world
flocking to the as of battalion to join
them now once you have co so think um
think isis and al-qaeda and how global
jihadism
uh if you had a battlefield how foreign
fighters would go they'd fight with that
jihadist group and then they'd hey you
got it i didn't even have to find it for
you yeah i'm i'm pretty good at google i
suppose uh far-right militias in europe
plan to confront russian forces a
research group says right so they're
flocking to join as of right now now the
problem here is what does that do
for radicalization if you end up
traveling across europe to join the as
of battalion you gain combat experience
fighting the russians and then you go
back to your country of origin
right you're now the equivalent of the
jihadi foreign fighter now we know what
effect that had with global jihadism
those that fought in afghanistan against
the soviet union
when the soviets occupied afghanistan
al-qaeda emerged from there global
jihadism spread from that combat
experience in afghanistan 9 11 happened
and the rest is history this is the
powder keg we've currently got what
happens though in europe in particular
is very interesting combine this new
york times article with the fact that
the video in fact you could probably
still pull up the video of the um
official ukrainian national guard
posting that video uh of the as of
battalion guy dipping bullets in
pigslard and the reason why that's
important pig's lard is everything yeah
pig's lard right pig fat so i'm gonna um
if you can't find it because it's on
twitter you may not be able to find it
but i'll find it as well and then just
at least what we can do is because the
audio he actually uses the word in their
language he uses the word muslims why
that's relevant is combine these two
pieces of news together
you've got the potential for foreign
fighter radicalization
this time with narcissism as opposed to
jihadism on european soil but europe's
never had more muslim citizens in
history than it currently has think
france for example 10 muslim
also europe has a radicalization problem
on the muslim side now going going back
to the great reset and the destruction
of the world order and build back better
this is the perfect way to encourage
civil war in europe with these
battle-hardened nazi fighters going back
to their countries of origin you've got
jihadis there already keep in mind the
chechens who are in ukraine at the
behest of putin
is who the azov battalion was talking
about when they said they were going to
dip their bullets in pig's lard to shoot
church and muslims now the problem here
you got is so they've gone to fight
muslims in chechen muslims in ukraine
they come back to their countries of
origin and they find islamist muslims in
their own countries of origin what i
worry about
is this leading
to radical reciprocal radical
radicalization in european countries and
that civil conflict emerging in
continental europe one of the most uh
valuable things any great reset is a
civil war yeah exactly right and and
it's incredibly worrying because we've
already had a genocide in europe in
bosnia with muslims and you end up with
with this situation
and and you know we've been funding
these we've been funding this nazi
battalion what was the bosnian genocide
it was a it was a genocide against
bosnia muslims when during the bosnian
war
1990s early 90s and how many people died
so in srebrenica in this revenue
massacre you had i think it was six
thousand bosnian muslim men and boys
geez in one day in a mass grave in one
attack wow yeah in one of them this was
just the bosnian government or was there
this is the sub serbian croatian bosnian
so
the the the former sort of the so
there was interestingly the olympics
were also ahead they're held there just
before this happened the olympics always
get involved in these sorts of things
remember hitler had the olympic games as
well
yeah it's crazy but yeah it and this is
in living memory by the way right so
this is when so when i was 15
and 14 this genocide was happening and
it radicalized an entire generation of
european muslims oh well this is when i
was 12 and i remember clinton the
bosnian war was all about serbia
and so he sent troops in to stop the
genocide was that the intent that's so
kosovo came immediately after that and
so he sent troops in the the ostensible
declared attempt intent was to stop it
happening again in kosovo where albanian
muslims were
just after the bosnia genocide but the
dayton accords is what emerged from that
yeah it's clinton's dating accord and
they did that tournament in nato or
something the dayton accords i don't
know about this so so the date in
accords was a deal that he struck um
with the serbs involving the kosovans to
stop the war
uh expanding into kosovo but the
genocide had already happened by then
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there